pour ce niveau de coopération entre nos
pays et cette semaine marquera un an de
combat un an de notre combat contre
l'agression russe il est donc très
symbolique que nous solidifions notre
résilience à grâce à deux réunions
ma visite au mois de décembre et la des
visites du président Biden
se verra et se reflétera très
certainement sur le champ de bataille
pour libérer notre territoire
les États-Unis
qui nous ont livrés des chars
ont montré déjà une forte consolidation
cette coordination nous aide pour notre
protection de notre espace aérien c'est
un fort renforcement de nos capacités
nous avons également parlé de armes de
longues portées ainsi que d'autres armes
qui pourraient être livrées à l'Ukraine
et qui n'avait pas encore été livré
je sais Monsieur le Président
qu'il y aura une grand paquet de soutien
à la sécurité de l'Ukraine cela enverra
un message clair
à savoir que l'agression de la Russie
est voué à échouer que nous allons
protéger défendre nos villes et nos
citoyens contre les Russes
cela nous aidera à décrocher la victoire
et aujourd'hui nous avons à nouveau
souligné que nous avons une vision
commune quant au perspective de cette
guerre
nous avons exercé une pression sur cet
état terroriste nous avons renforcé les
sanctions bilatérales et par le biais du
G7 ce qui est très important
il est très important d'avoir une vision
commune sur le contenu de différents
aspects
la sécurité l'élément de sécurité est
important
ainsi que la restauration de la Charte
des Nations Unies en sa pleine capacité
pour restaurer l'ordre international
voilà notre mission commune la mission
qui a combat tous les pays qui sont
intéressés par la sécurité
internationale
la reconstruction le redressement de la
justice est également important pour
toutes celles et ceux qui ont été
affectées par la guerre de terreur de la
Russie et la Russie doit assumer sa
responsabilité dans cette guerre je
tiens à remercier le président des
États-Unis pour son soutien pour son
aide pour restaurer la justice en
particulier dans toutes nos institutions
les galets juridiques et nous pensons
que aucune alternative à l'établissement
de la tribunal spécial ne peut exister
c'est la position de l'Ukraine
et nous soutiendrons cette position
j'aimerais que les États-Unis soient
engagés dans la mise en œuvre de notre
programme de paix car sa mise en œuvre
permettra de renforcer la stabilité
mondiale et la prévisibilité des
relations internationales
et nous avons déjà fait de grands
progrès dans ce domaine cette semaine
déjà à New York aux côtés des Nations
unies ou des États-Unis d'Amérique
un projet de résolution pour soutenir la
paix en Ukraine sera présentée aux
Nations Unies et le 24 février
nous espérons que cette résolution
montre RA
que un état voyou ne pourra jamais
briser un pays civilisé
nous ouvrons
nous avons des conversations régulières
avec le président Biden
ce qui est important pour la protection
de la démographie de la démocratie en
Ukraine
le soutien du président Biden a permis
de solidifier renforcer notre démocratie
c'est quelque chose dont nous
souviendrons toujours l'Ukraine et vous
est reconnaissante monsieur le Président
est reconnaissante à tous les
Américaines et toutes les Américains et
tous les Américains
gloire à l'Ukraine
gloire à nos alliés
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
cela fait un an cette semaine que nous
sommes entretenus au téléphone monsieur
le Président
c'était très tard à Washington très tôt
ici à Kiev
les avions russes étaient dans les airs
les chars traversaient votre frontière
vous m'avez dit
que vous pouviez entendre des explosions
je n'ai jamais oublié cela
[Musique]
le monde allait changer je m'en souviens
de manière très car je vous ai
demandé ensuite
monsieur le Président
que puis-je faire pour vous comment
puis-je vous aider
je ne sais pas si vous vous souvenez de
votre réponse vous m'avez dit je vous
cite
rassembler les dirigeants du monde
demandez-leur de soutenir l'Ukraine
rassemblez les dirigeants du monde et
et vous m'avez dit
que vous ne saviez pas si nous pourrions
nous entretenir à nouveau cette terrible
nuit il y a un an
le monde s'attendait à la chute de Kiev
on a l'impression que c'était il y a
plus d'un an mais c'était il y a un an
on pensait peut-être à la fin de
l'Ukraine
un an plus tard Kiev est toujours debout
et l'Ukraine est toujours debout la
démocratie tiens bon les Américains sont
à vos côtés et le monde est à vos côtés
également
Kiev a volé une partie de mon cœur je
suis venu six fois en tant que
vice-président une fois en tant que
Président
[Musique]
lorsque je suis venu ici en 2014 je suis
venu trois fois après la
Révolution
je suis venu en 2015 également
pour m'adresser à l'Assemblée pour
parler
des travaux et des efforts à faire pour
bâtir une démocratie solidaire je suis
revenu en 2017 juste avant de quitter
mes fonctions en tant que vice-président
je savais que je serai de retour
une fois que nous avons
terminé notre mandat j'ai décidé de
revenir en Ukraine avant le que le
prochain président prête serment
c'est un véritable honneur que vous
m'offrez ici aujourd'hui à Kiev
c'est un honneur pour moi de rencontrer
vos services du renseignement votre
armée vos services diplomatiques les
dirigeants de vos communautés qui ont
aidé leur pays
dans une période difficile tout le monde
s'est mobilisé de manière incroyable
tout le monde
les femmes les jeunes enfants
ont essayé d'agir de faire quelque chose
des personnes ont vu leur logement
détruit c'était un crime de guerre
[Musique]
et le monde entier et témoin de ses
atrocités
et vous vous défendez vous vous défendez
avec brio contre toute attente sauf les
vôtres nous allons s'assurer que vous
continuez à pouvoir vous descendre
à pouvoir vous défendre vous savez
il y a environ un an
[Musique]
nous étions en train d'essayer de
déterminer comment nous pourrions
mobiliser le monde occidental comment je
pourrais vous aider comment je pourrais
mobiliser les dirigeants mondiaux comme
vous m'aviez demandé de le faire
comment réussir comment faire en sorte
que le monde réagisse
[Musique]
une économie prospère une démocratie
solide à un état sur et indépendante
lorsque les Américains
Unis ont décidé
de se mobiliser les Américains
pour tous
de l'Atlantique au Pacifique nous sommes
mobilisés
l'OTAN le Japon au Pacifique vraiment
les quatre coins du monde se sont
mobilisés
plus de 50 nations ce sont levées
pour aider l'Ukraine à se défendre
en offrant une aide sans précédent une
aide humanitaire économique
le monde impose des sanctions qui vont
miner l'économie russe ensemble
nous avons livré 700 charges et des
milliers de blindés
mais le système d'artillerie
plus de 2 millions de séries de
munitions
aériens tout cela pour défendre
l'Ukraine
et il y a également 500 millions de
dollars que nous annonçons aujourd'hui
et que nous annoncerons demain 500
millions de dollars qui arriveront
et cela concerne que les États-Unis
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
nous annonçons la livraison de plus de
javelot de plus de 6 radars de
surveillance aérienne pourraient
protéger les yeux criniens contre les
bombardements aériens un petit peu plus
tard cette semaine nous allons annoncer
de sanctions supplémentaires contre les
élites et les entreprises
russes
et grâce à une
décision bip artisanale au Congrès nous
apportons un nouveau soutien des
milliards de dollars de soutien
budgétaires que le gouvernement peut
utiliser dès aujourd'hui pour aider ses
citoyens à leur apportant les services
de base
le coup porté par l'Ukraine a été
extrêmement élevé
et les sacrifices ont été bien trop
grands
nous pleurons à vos côtés nous pleurons
la perte de proche
si on trouvait la mort dans cette guerre
brutale nous savons que des jours des
semaines des années difficiles nous
attendent mais l'objectif de la Russie
était de supprimer la l'Ukraine de la
carte la guerre de Poutine était une
guerre de conquête une guerre qui échoue
l'armée
russe a perdu déjà la moitié des
territoires occupés
les Russes fuient
et ne veulent pas revenir en Russie
les Russes déserte et quittent même leur
pays
car ils ne voient aucun avenir dans leur
l'économie russe est aujourd'hui en
décrépitude
Poutine pensait que l'Ukraine était
faible et que l'Occident était divisé
comme vous le savez monsieur le
Président je vous l'ai dit dès le début
il comptait
sur le fait que nous allions nous
désolidariser il s'attendait à ce que
nous ne pouvions pas unir l'OTAN
il espérait que nous ne soyons pas en
mesure de venir en aide à l'Ukraine il
pensait pouvoir tenir plus longtemps que
nous
je ne pense pas qu'il pense ceci
aujourd'hui on se demande bien ce ce
qu'il pense
il s'est tout simplement fourvoyé
il s'est trompé sur toute la ligne
et un an plus tard
l'épreuve sont devant nous
nous sommes ensemble
monsieur le Président
je suis ravi de pouvoir à mon tour
revenir dans votre pays
à Washington vous nous avez dit vous
avez dit au Congrès nous n'avons aucune
crainte et le monde ne devrait pas avoir
peur non plus
vous et tous les Ukrainiens monsieur le
Président rappelez au monde
jour après jour ce que signifie le mot
courage
dans tous les secteurs de votre économie
toute la population c'est incroyable
[Applaudissements]